From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life.
这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目。
My name is Ken Hegan, and I'm a travel writer.
我叫肯·赫根，是一名旅行作家。
How tall are you?
你有多高？
I'm 6'2".
我身高6英尺2英寸。
So I'm on a flight to Minneapolis sitting next to Ken Hegan, 6'2" travel writer. And Ken is trying to pull off a scheme that is not at all friendly, though, to his credit, he feels bad about what he's doing.
我现在正坐在一架飞往明尼阿波利斯的航班上，坐在我旁边的是6英尺2英寸的旅行作家肯·赫根。肯正试图实施一个一点也不友好的计划，不过值得肯定的是，他对自己所做的事情感到愧疚。
So explain what just happened here.
那么，请解释一下刚才发生了什么。
Well, I can tell you I've only had about four hours sleep chiefly because I was a little nervous about trying something new. What I just did was I clamped these two pieces of plastic that look like the monsters from Alien-- like those little alien heads-- and they're clamps. You basically slide these clamps onto your tray table, and it prevents the person in front of you from tilting back and slamming into your knees, if you're a tall man like I am.
嗯，我只能告诉你，我只睡了大约四个小时，主要是因为我对于尝试新事物感到有点紧张。我刚才做的是把这两个看起来像《异形》里的怪物的塑料片夹上——就像那些小小的异形头——它们是夹子。你基本上可以把这些夹子滑到你的小桌板上，如果像我这样个子高的人坐着，它就能防止前面的人把座位向后调，撞到你的膝盖。
He'd read about these clamps on the internet and thought that is simultaneously the most inventive and the most passive aggressive gadget he'd ever heard of. It's called the Knee Defender. And as a tall guy who flies two or three times a month for his job, he decided he had to try them. Attaching the clamps to the arms of his tray table was simple, but next came the part that kept Ken awake the night before.
他在网上读到了关于这些夹子的信息，认为这是他听说过的最有创意同时也最消极反抗的小玩意儿。它叫“膝盖防御者”。作为一个每个月因为工作要飞两三次的高个子，他决定必须试一试。把夹子安装到小桌板的扶手上很简单，但接下来发生的事让肯前一天晚上都没睡好。
The makers of Knee Defender have something called a courtesy card that you're supposed to then hand to the person in front of you to let them know you're deploying the Knee Defender clamps. So I just tapped the woman's shoulder in front of me, said this message is for you.
“膝盖防御者”的制造商提供一种所谓的礼貌卡，你应该把它递给坐在你前面的人，让他们知道你正在部署“膝盖防御者”夹子。所以我刚才拍了拍前面那位女士的肩膀，说这条消息是给你的。
The card says, "This is a Knee Defender courtesy card, TM--" trademark. "I am using Knee Defender, TM. Knee Defender, TM is a small plastic device that helps me protect myself by limiting how much the seat in front of me can recline. I wanted to let you know about this."
卡片上写着：“这是‘膝盖防御者’礼貌卡，TM——商标。我正在使用‘膝盖防御者’，TM。‘膝盖防御者’，TM是一个小型的塑料装置，通过限制前面座位的倾斜度来帮助我保护自己。我想让你知道这一点。”
And then underneath, Ken checked the box that said that her seat would be able to recline two inches. Ken had been scared that handling this to somebody, he was going to end up in some horrible argument with a stranger on a plane. He's Canadian-- not to put too fine a point on that. He just doesn't like confrontation.
然后在下面，肯勾选了那个表示她的座位将只能向后倾斜两英寸的方框。肯一直很担心把这个递给别人会让他和飞机上的陌生人发生可怕的争吵。他是加拿大人——不是想过度强调这一点。他只是不喜欢对抗。
We discuss what happens next. And remember, as we discuss this, we're sitting in the row directly behind the woman that he handed the card to, hoping that she cannot hear us because of the noise of the plane, which is louder than you might think.
我们讨论接下来的事情。记住，当我们讨论这个的时候，我们正坐在他递交卡片的那位女士后面的那一排，希望她因为飞机的噪音而听不到我们说话，飞机的噪音比你想象的要大。
So I hand her the card, and then my hands were sweaty and shaky. So for about a minute, I just sort of was paralyzed. Eventually, she handed me the card back and slight nodded her head, didn't say a word. Then I asked her, hey, are you OK with this? And then her tone changed. She sounded very cranky and said, yeah, you don't see me move my seat back, do you?
所以我把卡片递给她，然后我的手又汗又抖。所以大约有一分钟，我就那样瘫痪了。最后，她把卡片还给我，轻轻地点了点头，一句话也没说。然后我问她，嘿，你同意这样吗？然后她的语气变了。她听起来非常暴躁，说，是啊，你没看见我没把座位往后调吗？
And then you and I are sitting next to each other. You wrote a little note on a piece of paper. Do you want to just read what it said?
然后你我坐在一起。你在纸条上写了一行小字。你想读读上面写了什么吗？
Yeah, I wrote a little note to you because I couldn't really talk. And yeah, my note said, I feel like a total dick right now.
好的，我给你写了一张小纸条，因为我真的说不出话来。是的，我的纸条上写着，我现在感觉自己像个十足的混蛋。
I mean, how would you feel? Would you feel comfortable doing this?
我是说，你会怎么想？你觉得这样做舒服吗？
Me, no. No.
我？不。不。
Yeah, if somebody did this to me, I'd think, man, you're just being a bully. And I would immediately start looking for cues in their behavior beyond the card that they're a dick. I'd be like-- I'd be looking for extra reasons to hate them. So yeah, I'm conflicted right now because hey, I got some space here. My knees feel good. I'm still being a dick.
是的，如果有人对我这样做，我会想，伙计，你真是个恶霸。我会立即从他们除了卡片之外的行为中寻找线索，证明他们是个混蛋。我会——我会寻找额外的理由去恨他们。所以是的，我现在很纠结，因为嘿，我这儿有了点空间。我的膝盖感觉很好。但我仍然是个混蛋。
Yeah.
是的。
And I'm getting away with it.
而且我还侥幸成功了。
Well, you're getting away with it in the sense that her chair is up. Like, you're not getting away with it in a sense of she probably thinks you're a dick.
嗯，你是“侥幸成功”了，从她的椅子是直立的这个意义上来说。但从她可能认为你是个混蛋这个意义上来说，你并没有侥幸成功。
Absolutely true. Yeah.
绝对正确。是的。
This is not the kind of getting away with it that most of us want. Most of us want total getting away with it, which means we don't just get our way. In addition, nobody thinks badly of us. You know? Nobody judges. That's what we want. That's just as true for grown men as for little boys.
这不是大多数人都想要的那种“侥幸成功”。大多数人想要的是彻底的“侥幸成功”，这意味着我们不仅达到了目的，而且没有人对我们有负面看法。你知道吗？没有人评判。这就是我们想要的。这对成年男人和对小男孩一样适用。
Do you think you're going to use the courtesy card and the Knee Defender again?
你觉得你还会再次使用那张礼貌卡和“膝盖防御者”吗？
I will absolutely use the Knee Defender again. The card, I don't think I'm ever going to use this again. No, I feel too bad.
我绝对会再次使用“膝盖防御者”。那张卡片，我想我再也不会用了。不，我感觉太糟了。
So basically, your hope is going to be that the people, when they try to push their seat back, they're just going to think, oh, the seat's broken.
所以基本上，你的希望是，当人们试图把座位向后推时，他们只会想，哦，椅子坏了。
Yep. Yeah, basically, I'm going to be a sneak. Be tricky. Let them believe the seat's broken.
是的。是的，基本上，我要做一个卑鄙小人。耍点花招。让他们相信椅子坏了。
I totally relate to that choice. I think lots of us are like this-- sneaks on a plane. If we can get away with something completely with no one ever knowing, nobody judging us, and-- just as important-- nobody really hurt, we give it a shot.
我完全理解这种选择。我想我们很多人都是这样——飞机上的卑鄙小人。如果我们能毫无痕迹地做成某事，没有人知道，没有人评判我们，而且——同样重要的是——没有真正伤害到任何人，我们就会试一试。
Today on our program, we have stories of people sneaking their way through, putting one over, getting away with it. Some people justifying it by saying they're doing it for others, for the greater good. Some not bothering with that-- they just don't care.
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于人们通过欺骗手段蒙混过关、胜人一筹、侥幸成功的故事。有些人通过说他们这样做是为了他人、为了更大的利益来证明自己的行为是正当的。有些人甚至懒得那样做——他们根本不在乎。
We have a dad hauling marijuana for the sake of his family. We have you, our listeners, setting things on fire and cheating in school. We have politicians lying in a wholesale and utterly effective way for the sake of four-year-olds. Stay with us.
我们有为了家庭而偷运大麻的父亲。我们有你们，我们的听众，纵火和在学校作弊。我们有为了四岁小孩而进行全面且极其有效的欺骗的政客。请继续收听。
Act One, Take Your Kid to Work Day. Of course, the most important thing, if you want to get away with some kind of wrongdoing, is that you have a plan-- a foolproof, well thought out plan, with safeguards and contingencies along the way to guard against everything you could think of that could possibly, possibly go wrong. Domingo Martinez has this story about his parents and a plan of theirs years and years ago.
第一幕，“带孩子上班日”。当然，如果你想侥幸逃脱某种不法行为，最重要的事情就是你得有一个计划——一个万无一失、深思熟虑的计划，在过程中要有安全措施和应急预案，以防范你能想到的所有可能出错的事情。多明戈·马丁内斯带来了这个关于他父母和他们多年前的一个计划的故事。
By 1986, Dad had become a truck driver with nothing left to haul but marijuana. Through his early 30s, he could do little with the trucking business he'd inherited from Grandpa except watch as it crumbled around him.
到1986年，我爸爸成了一名卡车司机，除了大麻没什么可运的了。在他30出头的时候，对于从爷爷那里继承下来的运输业务，他几乎什么也做不了，只能眼睁睁地看着它在自己周围崩溃。
Back then, he began his days by throwing open the door to the bedroom I shared with my brother, Dan. He'd stand there in his underwear, looking like a tall diapered child, and say, you two get up. He would end the day drinking a lot of $1.50 Budweisers at the shanty bars that littered the port of Brownsville.
那时，他开始一天的生活就是推开我和哥哥丹共用的卧室门。他穿着内衣站在那儿，看起来像个穿着尿布的高个子孩子，说，你们俩起来。他通常会以在散布在布朗斯维尔港口的破烂酒吧里喝很多1.5美元的百威啤酒来结束这一天。
At home, Mom kept the bookkeeping. She watched the flow of money slow to a trickle and then stop outright when I was in middle school. My brother, sisters, and I knew things were dire when our mother stopped shopping at El Centro Supermarket-- the nice grocery store, as she'd always told us-- and started bringing home bags from Lopez Supermarket, the poor people grocery store.
在家里，妈妈负责记账。她看着钱的流动减缓成涓涓细流，然后在我上初中时彻底停止。当我妈妈不再去洛佩斯超市——那个她总是告诉我们的“穷人超市”——买东西时，我和哥哥姐姐们就知道情况不妙了。
One morning, Mom surprises me by showing up at my seventh grade algebra class and removing me, getting us on the road out of Brownsville, headed north. There's no explanation. "Sientáte y lla callete," she snaps at me. Sit down and shut up.
一天早上，妈妈出现在我七年级的代数课上，把我带走，开车离开了布朗斯维尔，向北驶去，这让我很惊讶。没有任何解释。“Sientáte y lla callete，”她冲我吼道。坐下，闭嘴。
I don't know why I didn't guess what we were doing that morning-- that Mom and I were lookouts for Dad, who was on the road somewhere behind us in one of his flat-nosed tractor trailers, carrying a large load of marijuana and headed north. I had heard the stories, knew some of the tactics of smuggling by this point, but I didn't make the connection-- that Mom and I were driving ahead of Dad to make sure the customs station was closed, and if it happened to be open, we were supposed to turn back and warn him.
我不知道那天早上我为什么没猜到我们在做什么——我和妈妈是在为爸爸放哨，他就在我们身后的某条路上，开着他的一辆平头拖拉机拖车，运载着一大批大麻向北行驶。到那时，我已经听过很多故事，了解了一些走私的战术，但我没有把它们联系起来——我和妈妈是在为爸爸前方探路，以确保海关站关闭，如果碰巧开着，我们就得掉头警告他。
This was back in the 1980s before the Patriot Act, when there were two US customs checkpoints blocking the migration of drugs, fruit, people, reptiles, and parrots on the roads between the United States and Mexico, both about 100 miles north of the Mexican border at highway choke points.
那是20世纪80年代《爱国者法案》出台之前，美国和墨西哥之间的道路上设有两个美国海关检查站，拦截毒品、水果、人、爬行动物和鹦鹉的迁徙，两个检查站都在墨西哥边境以北约100英里处的高速公路咽喉要道上。
The station on Highway 77 in Sarita was the busier and the better financed. The checkpoint in Hebbronville, though, was an airstream trailer with an attached carport to protect the agents from the sun. And it would often close for breakfast or lunch.
萨里塔77号高速公路上的检查站更忙碌，资金更充足。然而，赫布隆维尔的检查站是一个带有附属车棚的清风房车，用来保护特工免受阳光照射。它经常因为早餐或午餐时间而关闭。
So we were headed towards that one this morning, going north on Highway 281, driving through the scenery of asthmatic plants and stunted trees. The car is hot, no air conditioning. My mom and I are saying nothing to one another. We have each decided that the other is unworthy of conversation. We stare out the windows and think very different things.
所以那天早上我们正朝那个方向驶去，沿着281号高速公路向北，穿过哮喘植物和发育不良树木的风景。车里很热，没有空调。我和妈妈谁也不跟谁说话。我们都认为对方不值得交谈。我们凝视着窗外，想着非常不同的事情。
Mom is thinking about the $100 she and Dad had spent before 6 o'clock that morning-- $100 that would help them make $2,000 if things went right, because their first stop on this felony excursion was to Dad's cúrandera whom we knew as La Señora, Dad's personal witchdoctor, for an emergency session.
妈妈正在想她和爸爸那天早上6点前花掉的100美元——如果一切顺利，这100美元将帮助他们赚取2000美元，因为他们这次重罪之旅的第一站是爸爸的灵媒，我们称之为“拉塞尼奥拉”，也就是爸爸的私人巫医，进行紧急会话。
They were let right through at 5:00 in the morning, and they had only one burning question-- will the checkpoint be open? After years of sitting through these sessions with my grandmother, I didn't have to be there to know exactly how it went in the cúrandera's office.
他们凌晨5点就被放进去了，他们只有一个迫切的问题——检查站会开吗？在陪我祖母参加过这些会议多年后，我不需要在场就知道“灵媒”办公室里的过程到底是怎么样的。
La Señora is older, matronly, dresses in a thin frock with her hair pulled back in a bun. She has my parents sit across from her desk in a black leather love seat with chrome handles. A panorama of photos hang around her office, some wallet-sized, others larger and in portrait. A pencil sketch of a Camaro by one of her grandsons hangs next to a window.
“拉塞尼奥拉”年纪较大，有主母风范，穿着一件薄长袍，头发挽成发髻。她让我的父母坐在她桌子对面的一张带有铬合金扶手的黑色皮革双人沙发上。她的办公室周围挂着各种照片，有些是钱包大小的，有些更大，是肖像照。她孙子画的一张科迈罗汽车的铅笔素描挂在窗户旁边。
She listens closely to their question, nodding sleepily at their preoccupation, sympathizing, understanding. They've reached a decision, and they can't turn back, they tell her. They need to do it. No other choice anymore. She stands up abruptly and walks behind her desk, which is cluttered with sheets of notebook paper crawling with ink-- illegible notes, names of people, sets of cryptic numbers, home addresses of saints. She closes her eyes and scribbles something on her yellow legal pad-- nonsense to anyone else reading it.
她仔细倾听他们的问题，对他们的忧虑困倦地点着头，表示同情和理解。他们告诉她，他们已经做出了决定，不能回头了。他们需要这样做。已经没有别的选择了。她突然站起来，走到桌子后面，桌上堆满了密密麻麻写满墨水的笔记本纸——潦草的笔记、人名、一系列神秘的数字、圣徒的家庭住址。她闭上眼睛，在黄色的法律便签纸上乱涂乱画了一些东西——在别人看来是废话。
On her desk are two cheap leaded crystal bottles, each filled with a clear liquid. She gently reaches for a matching shot glass and lifts it to the light, making it sparkle. She places the glass on the surface before her and pours from one bottle, then the other. When the two clear liquids mix, they turn a deep crimson and thicken like plasma. She nods her head as if her suspicions have been confirmed.
桌上放着两个廉价的铅玻璃瓶，每个里面都装满了透明液体。她轻轻地拿起一个配套的酒杯，举向光线，让它闪闪发光。她把杯子放在面前的桌面上，从一个瓶子里倒出液体，然后是另一个。当两种透明液体混合时，它们变成了深红色，像血浆一样变稠。她点点头，好像她的怀疑得到了证实。
She produces a glass orb filled with water, sitting on a black plastic ring. She sits up straight, closes her eyes, and regulates her breathing into a loud, rhythmic inhalation, exhalation, that unconsciously forces Mom and Dad to do the same. After a few seconds, she opens her eyes suddenly and strikes the glass orb with a metal wand, making it ring in the clear morning air. Then she lifts the orb between her two pudgy hands and stares deeply into the inverted image of the room around it.
她拿出一个放在黑色塑料环上的装满水的玻璃球。她挺直身子，闭上眼睛，将呼吸调整成响亮而有节奏的吸气和呼气，这下意识地迫使妈妈和爸爸也这样做。几秒钟后，她突然睁开眼睛，用金属棒敲击玻璃球，让它在清澈的早晨空气中发出响声。然后，她将玻璃球举在她两只肉乎乎的手之间，深深地凝视着倒映在球中的房间影像。
Sitting opposite this chicanery and watching everything she does, you're drawn to the ritual, and you can't help but try to figure it out, too. No, she says with certainty. The checkpoint will not be open this morning. Go in peace. God be with you.
坐在这些骗术的对面，看着她所做的一切，你会被这种仪式所吸引，也不禁试图弄清楚它。不，她肯定地说。今天早上检查站不会开。平安去吧。上帝与你们同在。
When Mom and I reach the checkpoint at 11:45 that morning, it is very much open for business. A line of cars five deep stretches back from the underbudgeted airstream trailer. Our job now is to go through and then turn back around and report to Dad that his doom was indeed imminent.
当我们那天上午11点45分到达检查站时，它确实在开门营业。一排五辆车深的车队从资金不足的清风房车后方排开。我们现在的任务是穿过去，然后掉头回来，报告给爸爸，他的厄运确实迫在眉睫。
Mom is visibly shaken. She turns off the radio with a hard click and considers this-- considers her options. From the car, we can see a skinny middle-aged white guy in green Border Patrol garb, sitting on a reclining chair in the open doorway of the Airstream trailer. He's facing the cars as they pass under the tin roof. It must have been 110 degrees inside the trailer, 100 in the shade.
妈妈明显动摇了。她重重地关掉收音机，思考着这一点——思考她的选择。从车里，我们可以看到一个瘦削的中年白人男子穿着绿色边境巡逻队的制服，坐在清风房车敞开门口的一张躺椅上。他正面对着一辆辆从铁皮屋顶下经过的汽车。房车里一定是110度，阴凉处也有100度。
From his position, never bothering to get up, the agent sits fanning himself with the newspaper and sleepily peers into the cars, asking if everyone is an American citizen, waiting for an accented answer, smiling, and then waving them through, like a sympathetic priest granting absolution.
坐在那个位置，特工甚至懒得站起来，坐在那里用报纸扇着风，困倦地盯着过往的汽车，问每个人是否是美国公民，等待着带有口音的回答，微笑着，然后挥手让他们通过，就像一位仁慈的牧师在给予赦免。
Hi, where y'all going to today, asks the skinny little man. Mom's window is now only halfway open, and in her nervousness, she rolls it all the way up. Hi, sorry. I mean, San Antonio, as she opens the window. Y'all American citizens? Yes, she says, as she leans back so he could get a clear look at me, nodding my head. I don't say anything except the quiet yep when I nod, but he has not heard me.
“嘿，你们今天要到哪儿去？”瘦瘦的小个子问。妈妈的车窗现在只开了一半，她在紧张中把它完全摇了上去。“嘿，抱歉。我是说，去圣安东尼奥，”她打开窗户说。“你们是美国公民吗？”“是的，”她说，她向后靠，好让他能清楚地看到我，我点点头。除了点点头时轻轻地说了声“是的”，我什么也没说，但他没听见。
There is an uncomfortable pause, I think because they're supposed to hear your accent. There is an anxious beat, and he still hasn't let us go when I say, yes, I am, a bit too enthusiastically. Mom laughs nervously. She had been hoping our light skin would exonerate us without a problem.
有一个令人不安的停顿，我想是因为他们应该听到你的口音。有一个焦虑的瞬间，当我说“是的，我是”时，他还没让我们走，我说得太热情了。妈妈紧张地笑了。她一直希望我们的浅肤色能让我们毫无问题地免除检查。
Y'all have a nice day, he says, like he hasn't noticed anything awkward. We drive through, and I feel her seethe for the next few miles.
“祝你们今天过得愉快，”他说，就好像他没注意到任何尴尬一样。我们开过去了，在接下来的几英里里，我能感觉到她在那儿生闷气。
That was about noon. Somewhere behind us, at a roadside rest stop, Dad and my older brother Dan are waiting in Dad's tractor trailer, which is attached to the trailer with the marijuana. The two center I beams that run the length of the trailer make perfect housing once you weld metal plates all along the underside and at the tail end. It creates a long rectangular box sealed at the rear end with the axle of the rig, where 20 40-pound blocks of marijuana can be hidden. This is what Dad and Dan are carrying.
那是中午左右。在我们身后的某个地方，在一个路边休息站，爸爸和我哥哥丹正在爸爸的拖拉机拖车里等着，拖车上连接着装有大麻的挂车。沿着拖车长度延伸的两根中心工字梁，一旦你把金属板沿着底部和尾端焊起来，就形成了完美的住所。它创造了一个长方形的盒子，在装载装置的车轴处密封在后端，那里可以隐藏20个40磅重的大麻砖。这就是爸爸和丹正在携带的东西。
I wondered dimly if Dan has figured out what he's doing out here on the road north when he should be in high school. But Dan has always been more streetwise, much savvier than me. I figure that if I figured it out, he'd have figured it out long before.
我模糊地想，丹是否弄明白了他在路上向北行驶时本该在读高中的自己在做什么。但丹一直比我更了解社会，更精明。我想，如果我弄明白了，他一定早就弄明白了。
Mom and I drive on to Hebbronville. I'm dehydrated. I want to stop at a store. We can't, she says to me. We have to turn back. I think we're behind.
我和妈妈开车去赫布隆维尔。我脱水了。我想在商店停下来。我们不能，她对我说。我们必须回去。我想我们落后了。
Still, I'm hungry and really thirsty, so I persist. Certainly we have time to go to a convenience store. They can't have scheduled this thing to hinge on a few minutes. Certainly they've devised this more cleverly than that. Please, I plead. Just stop at the 7-Eleven.
尽管如此，我还是很饿，非常口渴，所以坚持要求。我们肯定有时间去便利店。他们不可能把这件事安排得只差几分钟。他们肯定设计得比那聪明多了。拜托，我恳求道。就停在7-Eleven好了。
Grudgingly, she pilots the noisy car around the small town and finds a convenience store. I get out with a couple of dollars and come up short when I try paying for some donuts and a chocolate milk. I return to the car for more money. Just get in, she yells. And I do, leaving the food at the counter. Mom whips the car around, and I'm in trouble, used to it by now.
她勉强驾驶着那辆嘈杂的车绕过小镇，找到了一家便利店。我带着几美元下车，在试图付甜甜圈和巧克力牛奶钱时，发现钱不够。我回到车上拿更多的钱。“快上车，”她吼道。我照做了，把食物留在了柜台上。妈妈把车猛地调转过来，我惹上麻烦了，对此我已经习以为常了。
We travel like that for a few minutes. And when the checkpoint is back in sight, we hold our breath so the guy won't see us. And right then, we see Dad and Dan and the trailer heading right for the checkpoint. Dad had become nervous, or maybe brave, or maybe he was blinded by his $100 faith in his cúrandera and had charged forth without waiting for Mom's report.
我们就那样开了几分钟。当再次看到检查站时，我们屏住呼吸，免得那家伙看到我们。就在那时，我们看到了爸爸和丹，还有那辆正径直朝检查站开去的挂车。爸爸变得紧张了，或者也许是勇敢了，又或者他被他对灵媒的100美元信心蒙蔽了，没等妈妈的报告就冲了出去。
Oh, god, my mother says. And all the blood drains from my face from just the tone in her voice. I had never heard her voice so charged with fear. Oh, god, she says again. With her left hand, she grabs the knob that controls the headlights and flashes at Dad, who is only a few hundred feet from the checkpoint. She flashes four times, in clear view of anyone who is paying attention.
“哦，上帝，”我妈妈说。听到她声音里的那种语调，我脸上的血色一下子全没了。我从未听过她的声音如此充满恐惧。“哦，上帝，”她又说了一遍。她用左手抓住控制前灯的旋钮，对离检查站只有几百英尺远的爸爸闪烁了几下。她在任何注意的人的清晰视野下闪烁了四次。
I wonder if that is her signal that the checkpoint is open, but question the wisdom of doing it while he is next in line in full view of the guy at the checkpoint, were he to look over his shoulder and see the noisy southbound car that just drove through not 30 minutes before.
我不知道那是她发出的检查站开放的信号，但质疑在他在检查站的人眼皮底下排队时这样做是否明智，如果那个特工回头看，看到那辆30分钟前才开过去的吵闹的南行车，那该怎么办。
She slows down, slows terrifically down, going less than 20 miles per hour on the highway. And for a moment, I can see Dad is driving. I can see that the blood is drained from his face, too, making his eyebrows stand out a rich black on his pallid, deathly white forehead, a mask of someone pretending desperately that everything is A-OK, but doing it horrifically badly.
她减速了，减速得非常厉害，在高速公路上以低于每小时20英里的速度行驶。片刻间，我能看到爸爸正在开车。我能看到他脸上的血色也没了，使他的眉毛在他苍白、死灰般的额头上显得异常浓黑，那是一个人试图绝望地假装一切都很好，但装得极度糟糕的面具。
I see Dan in the passenger seat, holding onto the handrail above the door as a means to steady himself through this craziness, through this stupid, unnecessary risk. And he looks calm, collected, uncaring, like he isn't there.
我看到丹坐在副驾驶座上，抓着门上方的扶手，以此在这一切疯狂、这种愚蠢且不必要的冒险中稳住自己。他看起来冷静、从容、毫不在乎，好像他根本不在这里。
There are no cars ahead of them now. The trailer is next in line. It slows to a crawl, and I could see Dad desperately trying to ignore the crazy, flashing, noisy Bonneville, rattling through the southbound lane, keeping his eyes fixed to the road, pretending like he isn't smuggling anything in the empty trailer behind him, this empty, useless trailer with the I beams all sealed up, with the two Mexican men driving it, with no obvious destination, no paperwork, no affiliation with any hauling or trucking company.
现在他们前面没有车了。挂车排在下一位。它减速到爬行，我能看到爸爸绝望地试图忽略那辆疯狂、闪烁、吵闹的邦纳维尔轿车，在南行车道上发出嘎嘎声，眼睛盯着路面，假装他没有在他后面的空挂车里走私任何东西，这个装有工字梁密封起来的、无用的、空空的挂车，载着两个开着它的墨西哥人，没有明显目的地，没有文书，没有隶属于任何运输或卡车公司。
No, sir, not trafficking in drugs. Just driving through, to Houston probably, looking for work. Oh, yes, we're American citizens. That's not why we're nervous. We could prove that. That's nothing. We're nervous because of the pot we're hiding, and because we're only getting $2,000 for risking upwards of 10 years in prison. Isn't that funny? Isn't that just hysterical? But the skinny white guy is having lunch and can't be bothered.
“不，先生，不是在贩毒。只是开车路过，可能是去休斯顿找工作。哦，是的，我们是美国公民。我们紧张不是因为这个。我们可以证明这一点。那不算什么。我们紧张是因为我们藏的大麻，还因为我们冒着高达10年的牢狱之灾只赚了2000美元。那不可笑吗？那不歇斯底里吗？”但那个瘦削的白人正在吃午饭，没空搭理。
In one of the weirder moments of this whole debacle, the Bonneville, the Airstream, and dad's tractor are all lined up like some cosmic event, and we see the skinny Border Patrol agent, with a white napkin tucked under his chin, and Dad's bloodless face up in the trailer through the window of the Airstream, as the agent waves him through with a fork, like he's conducting an orchestra. Go on through. Go on through.
在整个闹剧中最奇怪的时刻之一，邦纳维尔车、清风房车和爸爸的拖拉机都像某种宇宙事件一样排成一列，我们看到那位瘦削的边境巡逻特工，下巴下塞着一张白餐巾，透过房车的窗户看到爸爸在挂车里血色全无的脸，特工用叉子指引他通过，就像在指挥交响乐团一样。走吧，过去吧。过去吧。
Mom continues driving south, stunned by what has just happened. And I'm careful not to say a word. We almost reach Raymondville and stop at a Whataburger to get a quick, wordless lunch, then spend some time sitting in a parking lot, waiting. When she feels it is safe to return, she turns the car around and heads back north, back through the same checkpoint. Are you sure this is safe, I ask. She doesn't answer.
妈妈继续向南开，被刚刚发生的事情惊呆了。我小心翼翼地一个字也不说。我们几乎到达了雷蒙德维尔，在沃特堡停下来吃了一顿匆忙、无声的午餐，然后在停车场坐了一会儿，等着。当她觉得安全可以回去时，她把车调转方向，向北开去，再次穿过同一个检查站。“你确定这安全吗？”我问。她没回答。
When we pull up again to the checkpoint, headed back to Hebbronville, around 3 o'clock, there was a different Border Patrol agent at the Airstream. He is a small, clean cut militant Mexican with a Southern drawl. Y'all American citizens, he demands instantly, leaning into the car through the window, clearly smelling for marijuana smoke.
当我们再次到达检查站，准备回赫布隆维尔时，大约是3点钟，清风房车处换了一个边境巡逻特工。他是一个瘦小的、打扮干净、带有南方口音的墨西哥裔激进分子。“你们都是美国公民吗？”他立刻质问，通过窗户向车里探过身来，显然在嗅有没有大麻烟味。
Oh, yes, says my mother, who is probably quite relieved the hard part is over, and it looks like we're getting away with it. How about you, son? You American citizen? He gives me a direct glare through reflective sunglasses. There is nothing more potentially hostile than the indigenous ego interpreting the laws of his conquerer upon his own people.
“哦，是的，”我妈妈说，她可能很庆幸最困难的部分已经过去了，看起来我们就要侥幸成功了。“你呢，孩子？你是美国公民吗？”他透过反光太阳镜直接盯着我。没有什么比本土自我将其征服者的法律解读为本族人民身上更具潜在敌意的事情了。
Yes, sir, I say, careful not to move or fidget or look away like I've learned. He looks back at my mother, then at me, like he smells the nervousness of earlier. Something tugs at his intuition. Where are y'all headed, the sunglasses finally ask. This catches Mom off guard. Her subterfuge had ended when Dad had driven through the checkpoint. She left all her answers back in Raymondville.
“是的，先生，”我说，小心地不乱动、不烦躁，也不像我学到的那样移开视线。他看着我妈妈，又看着我，好像他闻到了之前那种紧张感。有什么东西触动了他的直觉。“你们打算去哪儿？”太阳镜最终问。这让妈妈措手不及。她的诡计在爸爸开车穿过检查站时就已经结束了。她把所有的答案都留在了雷蒙德维尔。
We're going to Hebbronville, she says unconvincingly. Had he asked one more question, had he pressed it, we would have been in some sort of trouble. But he doesn't, and he backs off and motions us through.
“我们要去赫布隆维尔，”她毫无说服力地说。如果他多问一个问题，如果他施加压力，我们就会陷入某种麻烦。但他没有，他退后一步，示意我们通过。
Mom drives the noisy car through Hebbronville, and we are about to hit the open highway again when we noticed Dad's trailer in the parking lot of a cheap motel by the side of the road. My brother is lodged between the rearmost tires, working on the brake lights that ridiculously aren't working. Mom is as alarmed to find them there as I am. This confirms my suspicion that there had been no planning beyond the consultation at the cúrandera's. This whole debacle had been based on nothing more than $100 worth of faith.
妈妈驾驶着那辆嘈杂的车穿过赫布隆维尔，我们正准备再次驶上开阔的高速公路时，我们注意到爸爸的挂车停在路边一家廉价汽车旅馆的停车场里。我哥哥被夹在最外面的轮胎之间，正在修理滑稽地无法工作的刹车灯。妈妈发现他们在那儿和我一样感到震惊。这证实了我的怀疑：除了在灵媒那里的咨询之外，根本没有计划。整场闹剧都是建立在100美元的信念之上的。
Mom pulls up next to the trailer, and I think she expects a victorious reunion. When he sees her, Dad suddenly looks like he's about to punch her. Stupid [BLEEP] woman, he yells at her in Spanish. Mom stops cold. What the [BLEEP] were you thinking? If they would have just turned around for a moment, it would all be over, and it would all be your fault, he spits at her in Spanish. We realize what he's upset about-- the flashing headlights.
妈妈把车停在挂车旁边，我想她期待着一场胜利的重逢。当他看到她时，爸爸突然看起来像是要揍她。“愚蠢的[哔]女人，”他用西班牙语对她大吼。妈妈僵住了。“你[哔]在想什么？”“如果他们只是掉头转一下，一切就都完了，那全会是你的错，”他用西班牙语冲她咆哮。我们意识到他为什么生气——闪烁的前灯。
His words continue to snap and hiss around her like bullets in a firefight, and she follows him forward to the cab of the truck, kowtowing to her punishment. Lucky for us, la Senora was right, Dad says, walking back with Mom, now excited and seemingly over his anger. She made him blind, and we were let through like they were closed.
他的话语像交火中的子弹一样在她周围噼啪作响，发出嘶嘶声，她跟着他向前走到卡车驾驶室，卑躬屈膝地接受惩罚。“我们运气好，拉塞尼奥拉说对了，”爸爸走回来时说，带着妈妈，现在兴奋起来，似乎不再生气了。她让他瞎了眼，我们就像检查站关门一样被放行了。
When we left them later that evening, Dan was doing the driving. They pulled out of the parking lot and headed off to Houston and their payoff, the brake lights temporarily fixed in loops of black electrical tape. I watch as the truck disappears. It looks like every other piece of now broken down equipment we've ever owned-- rusting, miserable, and totally criminal.
那天晚上晚些时候我们离开他们时，丹在开车。他们驶离停车场，前往休斯顿去拿报酬，刹车灯暂时用黑色电工胶带缠绕固定。我看着卡车消失。它看起来就像我们曾经拥有的每一件现在已经破烂不堪的设备一样——生锈、悲惨，且完全是犯罪工具。
Mom and I turn south back to Brownsville. Mom is her usual quiet self, except this time, she plays the radio louder. This means she's thinking. It's getting dark, and I'm sleepy, so I sleep. She'll get us home. She knows the way. For that, I could trust her.
我和妈妈转向南边回布朗斯维尔。妈妈还是她平时安静的样子，只是这一次，她把收音机开得更大声了。这意味着她在思考。天黑了，我很困，所以我就睡了。她会带我们回家的。她认得路。为了这一点，我可以信任她。
Domingo Martinez reading a story from his collection, The Boy Kings of Texas, which is a memoir and a finalist for the National Book Award.
多明戈·马丁内斯正在朗读他合集《德克萨斯男孩王》中的一个故事，这是一部回忆录，也是美国国家图书奖的入围作品。
Act Two, Get Away With It After the Beep. So today's show is a rerun. And a couple weeks before it originally was broadcast, we invited listeners to call into a special phone number that we set up here at the radio show and tell us what things you have gotten away with. Over 1,000 of you called.
第二幕，“哔”声之后侥幸成功。今天的节目是重播。在它最初播出前几周，我们邀请听众拨打我们在广播节目中设立的一个特殊电话号码，告诉我们你们侥幸做成过什么事情。超过一千名听众打来了电话。
Our intern back then, Tarek, listened to those messages, and he said that he came away from the experience seeing you all very, very differently than he had before. He said that if these messages are any indicator at all, most of you have either cheated in school or committed some small act of arson at some point in your lives.
我们当时的实习生塔雷克听了那些留言，他说他从这次经历中看待你们所有人的眼光与以前非常、非常不同。他说，如果这些留言有任何迹象的话，你们大多数人要么在学校作弊过，要么在人生的某个阶段犯下过某种小小的纵火行为。
So, good to know. I know we should try to capitalize on that during the pledge drive. I have no idea how, but anyway, here's a small selection of the messages that we received.
好吧，很高兴知道。我知道我们应该在认捐期间利用这一点。我不知道该怎么利用，但总之，这里是我们收到的留言的一小部分精选。
We found new ways of cheating on tests, homework. We're not proud of it, or at least I'm not proud of it. But it's what we did. We learned Morse Code, would tap during class.
我们找到了在考试、家庭作业中作弊的新方法。我们对此并不自豪，或者至少我不自豪。但这就是我们所做的。我们学会了莫尔斯电码，在课堂上敲击。
I, by all rights, should not have graduated. And I shouldn't have gone to college, which is what wound up happening.
按理说，我本不应该毕业。我本不应该上大学，但结果却变成了那样。
I got away with graduating high school by lying to my dean and telling her that I had HIV.
我通过对院长撒谎说我得了艾滋病，侥幸从高中毕业了。
In my sophomore year of high school, I turned in a stick for my final project.
在我高二那年，我交了一根棍子作为我的期末项目。
And I'm embarrassed to tell you that I got away with a little bit of extortion. I suggested to him that if I could pass his class with a much better grade, that what I saw in the Super 8 would stay just between us.
我很尴尬地告诉你们，我曾侥幸进行过一点敲诈。我暗示他，如果我能以更好的成绩通过他的课，我在“超级8”电影里看到的事情就会在我们之间保密。
Entering the church, we saw a giant earthworm on the ground in the parking lot. I picked it up and put it in my pocket. And before the service started, my brother and I were playing with it by ourselves. My brother dared me to put it in the hair of a girl in front of us, and I decided to do it. And so I put it in her hair, but because her hair was so frizzy-- it was the '80s-- the worm disappeared, and she didn't feel anything.
进入教堂时，我们在停车场地上看到一条巨大的蚯蚓。我把它捡起来放进了口袋。在礼拜开始前，我和哥哥在独自玩它。哥哥怂恿我把它放到前面一个女孩的头发里，我决定照做。于是我把它放进她的头发里，但因为她的头发太卷了——那是80年代——虫子消失了，她什么也没感觉到。
I got away with being the featured speaker in a seminar to which I was not even invited.
我侥幸成为了一场我根本没受邀请参加的研讨会的特邀发言人。
I'd like to tell you how I got away with posing as the president's cousin to get health care at a hospital in Tajikistan.
我想告诉你们我是怎么冒充总统的表弟在塔吉克斯坦的一家医院获得医疗服务的。
It's this incredible rush because it had worked. I was able to act my way out of being murdered.
这是一种不可思议的快感，因为这奏效了。我通过演戏逃脱了被谋杀的命运。
I was parked at a stoplight next to a girl I was trying to impress, and I decided to race her from stoplight to stoplight. So I slammed on the accelerator, and just as I was flying past her, a cop was going the other way. So he does a U-turn. I make a quick right down a side street, hoping he'll chase that girl, but of course, he didn't. He came after me.
我把车停在红绿灯处，旁边是一个我想打动的女孩，我决定在红绿灯之间和她赛车。所以我猛踩油门，就在我飞驰过她身边时，一个警察正从对面过来。于是他掉头了。我迅速右转到一条小街，希望他去追那个女孩，但当然，他没有。他追的是我。
So I made another quick right up an alleyway. He was still coming after me, so I swooped in behind a garage, jumped out of my car, ran through some people's yards, crossed the main street of Sherman Avenue, and wondering what I'm going to do. I'm now without a car, and the police are looking for me. So I saw another cop car parked at a parking lot of the professional building, and I ran over and I said, oh my god, somebody just stole my car.
所以我又迅速右转进了一条小巷。他还在追我，所以我绕到一个车库后面，跳出车外，跑过一些人的院子，穿过了谢尔曼大街的主干道，不知道该怎么办。我现在没车了，警察在找我。所以我看到另一辆警车停在专业大楼的停车场，我跑过去说，天哪，有人刚刚偷了我的车。
We thought it would be fun to try to make flamethrowers with WD-40 and a lighter.
我们以为用WD-40润滑剂和一个打火机试着制作火焰喷射器会很有趣。
I didn't want to tell them or anybody else because at the time, I was 19 and could get in trouble for arson. So I kept that story to myself.
我不想告诉他们或任何人，因为当时我19岁，可能会因为纵火而惹上麻烦。所以我把那个故事藏在心里。
I knew it was us because I went back to the spot where I had smoked that cigarette with a friend. And sure enough, that part of the ground was black. And then I was like, yep, that's definitely us. I feel horrible about this now, but I ended up getting away with it.
我知道是我们，因为我回到了我和朋友抽烟的那个地方。果然，那块地方的地面是黑的。然后我就想，是的，那绝对是我们。我现在对此感到很糟糕，但我最终还是侥幸脱身了。
I kept it to myself, and it's the first time I'm revealing that secret.
我把它藏在心里，这是我第一次揭露这个秘密。
I got away with it and spent the rest of the night just giggling and eating junk food like you do.
我侥幸脱身，剩下的时间就只是咯咯笑和吃垃圾食品，像你平时做的那样。
OK, we have one final story from a listener-- kind of a long one.
好了，我们还有一位听众的最后一个故事——有点长。
I went to an acting conservatory in New York City for two years, and they told me about a month before graduation that it wouldn't be happening for me. I was, like, a credit and a half or two credits shy. And I was like, this is not a problem. I figured I'd find a way to work it out. I actually think I thought I would Ferris Bueller it somehow and actually be able to get my diploma.
我在纽约市的一所表演艺术学院待了两年，他们在毕业前一个月告诉我，这对我来说可能无法实现了。我当时还差一个半学分或两个学分。我心想，这没问题。我想我能找到办法解决它。我其实认为我会以某种方式像电影里的费里斯·布勒那样蒙混过关，并真正拿到毕业证。
I just kept telling my parents everything was fine, and they made plans to come to New York and go to the graduation. And they were going to make a whole weekend trip of the thing. And they came to town, and I knew I was not going to be able to walk and my name was not going to be called, so I sort of just planted things in their mind all weekend.
我一直告诉父母一切都很好，他们计划来纽约参加毕业典礼。他们打算把这事安排成一个周末旅行。他们来到城里，我知道我无法上台领证，我的名字也不会被念到，所以我周末整天在他们脑子里种下了暗示。
Like, you know, I hear graduation's four hours long. I hear a lot of people aren't going and made sure they got extremely drunk the night before and would be hung over the next day. The graduation was at 1:00. We were all dressed up and ready to go. I was like, you know what? Let's just skip it. Let's have a good day in New York and go do something fun instead.
比如，你知道，我听说毕业典礼要持续四个小时。我听说很多人都不去了，并确保他们前一天晚上喝得烂醉如泥，第二天会宿醉。毕业典礼是在下午1点。我们都盛装打扮准备出发。我说，你知道吗？我们要不去算了。我们在纽约过愉快的一天，去干点有趣的事吧。
So they bought it. And we just went out in New York, and I told my parents that I ended up getting a diploma in the mail to my apartment months later. And to this day, they still think I graduated from college when I didn't.
他们相信了。我们就在纽约四处游玩，我告诉父母我几个月后会收到寄到公寓的毕业证书。直到今天，他们仍然认为我从大学毕业了，其实我根本没有。
Interesting side note-- the only person I ever told that to in my family was my brother after he came out of the closet and told me he was gay. And I figured I'd tell him my big secret, too. And he went right and told my sister because that way, if I ever outed him, he'd be able to say I was a huge liar. So there you go.
一个有趣的题外话——我在家里唯一告诉过的人是我哥哥，在他出柜并告诉我他是同性恋之后。我想我也该告诉他我的大秘密。他转头就告诉了我姐姐，这样一来，如果我哪天曝光他，他就能反驳说我是个彻头彻尾的骗子。所以，就是这样。
Thanks to everybody who took the time to call. See you all in hell.
感谢所有花时间打电话的朋友。在地狱里见。
Well, coming up, 12-year-old ballerina con artist. You know, I have one thing written here to make you want to listen to this story, but that should be enough, right? That is enough right there. I'm just going to say it again-- 12-year-old ballerina con artist. Come on. You can't turn away without hearing that. That's coming up in just a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
好了，接下来，12岁的芭蕾舞演员诈骗犯。你知道，我在这里写了一句话来让你想听这个故事，但这应该就够了吧？那确实就足够了。我再重复一遍——12岁的芭蕾舞演员诈骗犯。来吧。你不可能在听了这些之后还不感兴趣。稍后即将播出，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Getting Away With It. We have stories of people doing just that and usually, not feeling so bad about it. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Crime and Tutus.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“侥幸成功”。我们有关于人们确实那样做，并且通常不会感到那么糟糕的故事。我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，“犯罪与芭蕾短裙”。
OK, parents, I would actually warn you not to let your kids hear this next story, except the thing that the children in this next story accomplish would be impossible for any kids to do today. Basically, they go to the airport, and they try to hop on a plane to go to another city. The comedian Molly Shannon told what happened to Marc Maron on his podcast, WTF, which is a great podcast. They did this in front of a live audience in November 2011.
好了，各位家长，我其实要警告你们不要让孩子们听到下一个故事，除非下一个故事中孩子们所完成的事情是今天任何孩子都不可能做到的。基本上，他们去机场，试图跳上一架飞机去另一个城市。喜剧演员莫莉·香农在马克·马伦的播客《WTF》（一个很棒的播客）上讲述了发生的事情。他们在2011年11月当着现场观众的面讲述了这个故事。
I hopped a plane when I was 12. We told my dad-- me and my friend Anna were like, we're going to hop a plane to New York. And he was like-- he dared us. So we went to the--
我12岁时跳上了一架飞机。我们告诉了我爸爸——我和朋友安娜说，我们要跳上一架飞机去纽约。他就像——他向我们发起挑战。所以我们去了——
How old were you?
你当时多大？
We were, like, 12.
我们大约12岁。
Oh, good. That's good.
哦，很好。那很好。
So we went to the airport, and we had ballet outfits on. And we put our hair in buns, and we wanted to look really innocent. And this was, again, when flying was really easy. You didn't need your ticket to get through. And we told my dad, and we were just like, we saw there were two flights. We were either going to go to San Francisco or New York.
所以我们去了机场，我们穿着芭蕾舞服。我们把头发盘成髻，我们想看起来非常天真。再一次，这是飞行非常容易的时候。你不需要机票就能通过安检。我们告诉了我爸爸，我们就看到有两班飞机。我们要么去旧金山，要么去纽约。
And we thought, oh, let's go to New York. It's leaving early. So we went. We said to the stewardess, we just want to say goodbye to my sister. Could we go on the plane? She was like, sure. And then she let us on, and it was a really empty flight because it was out of Cleveland, Ohio. And we sat back there, and then all of a sudden, you just hear like, vroom.
我们想，哦，去纽约吧。它很早就出发。所以我们去了。我们对空姐说，我们只是想和我的姐姐说再见。我们能上飞机吗？她说，当然可以。然后她让我们进去了，那是一个非常空的航班，因为它是从俄亥俄州克利夫兰出发的。我们坐在后面，然后突然间，你听到像“呜”的声音。
The plane takes off, and we were like-- and we had little ballet outfits and buns. And I was, like, hail Mary, full of grace. The Lord is with thee. Blessed art thou amongst women, and blessed is the fruit of thy womb, Jesus. Holy Mary, mother of God, pray for us sinners now and at the hour of our death. Amen.
飞机起飞了，我们当时就想——我们穿着小芭蕾舞服，盘着头。我当时就在念，万福玛利亚，满被圣宠者，主与尔偕焉。女中为福，尔胎子耶稣，并为福。天主圣母玛利亚，为我等罪人，今祈天主，及我等死后。阿门。
And then the stewardess had given us permission to go say good bye to my sister came by to ask if we wanted snacks or beverages. And she was like, can I get you ladies something to eat? She looked like she was like, oh, mother [BLEEP]. So we wondered if we were going to get in trouble, but she ended up not telling anyone. And then when we landed in New York City, she was like, bye, ladies. Have a nice trip.
然后那位允许我们去和姐姐说再见的空姐过来问我们是否想要零食或饮料。她说，我能给你们几位女士拿点吃的吗？她看起来像是说，哦，妈[哔]的。所以我们想知道我们是否会惹上麻烦，但她最后没有告诉任何人。然后当我们降落在纽约市时，她说，再见，女士们。祝你们旅途愉快。
It's such an exciting story, but the irresponsibility of all the adults in this story is somehow undermining my appreciation of it. You were 12-year-old girls in ballet outfits, and everybody's sort of like, have a good time. What world was that?
这是一个非常令人兴奋的故事，但这个故事中所有大人的不负责任在某种程度上削弱了我对它的欣赏。你们是穿着芭蕾舞服的12岁女孩，每个人都像说，祝你们玩得开心。那是什么世界？
It was crazy. It was a crazy world.
太疯狂了。那是一个疯狂的世界。
What did you do in New York?
你在纽约做了什么？
Well, again, because I had a crazy childhood, we call my dad. We were, like, we did it! And he was like, oh, god! Molly! Oh, jeez, well, try to-- so basically, he couldn't--
好吧，再一次，因为我有一个疯狂的童年，我们打电话给爸爸。我们说，我们成功了！他当时就说，哦，天哪！莫莉！哦，天哪，好吧，试着——所以基本上，他没能——
Try to what?
试着什么？
He didn't know what to do. He said try to see if you could stay-- go find a hotel that you could stay in.
他不知道该怎么办。他说试着看能不能找个酒店住下。
Oh my god.
天哪。
Me and Mary, my sister, will come meet you. We'll drive there. So basically, we were like, all right, we'll try to find a hotel. But he was kind of excited because he liked crazy stuff. But basically, we didn't have that much. We just had our ballet bags and a little bit of cash that we went to a diner, and we dined and dashed. And we stole things. We were like little con artists.
我和姐姐玛丽会去接你们。我们会开车去那儿。所以基本上，我们想，好吧，我们试着找个酒店。但他有点兴奋，因为他喜欢疯狂的事情。但基本上，我们没带多少钱。我们只有芭蕾舞包和一点现金，我们去了一家餐馆，吃了霸王餐。我们偷东西。我们就像小诈骗犯。
Wait, did you actually make it to the city?
等等，你们真的到了市区吗？
We made it to the city. I was like, how do you get to Rockefeller Center? Because I had just seen TV scenes--
我们到了市区。我当时想，怎么去洛克菲勒中心？因为我刚在电视上看到过场景——
And nobody said, are you girls lost? Nothing like that?
而且没人说，你们女孩迷路了吗？没发生类似的事？
No, nothing. So we did try to go to hotels, and my dad would call and ask, could they just stay there until we get there? And none of the hotels wanted to be responsible.
没有，什么也没有。所以我们确实试着找酒店，我爸爸会打电话问，她们能在你们那儿待到我们过去吗？没有酒店想承担责任。
Oh my god.
天哪。
So he was like, all right, you got to come home. And he was like, but I'm not paying for it, so try to hop on one on the way back. So we tried to hop on many planes, but it was the flights were all so crowded.
所以他说，好吧，你们得回家。他说，但我不会付钱的，所以试着在回去的路上跳上一架飞机。所以我们试着跳上许多飞机，但航班都太拥挤了。
Right.
对。
So we ended up having to have him pay for it, and he made us pay it all back with our babysitting money.
所以我们最后不得不让他付钱，他让我们用保姆赚的钱把钱都还给他。
Oh.
哦。
The end.
结束。
So that was the big punishment?
所以那就是大惩罚？
Yeah, that was-- there was no punishment.
是的，那就是——根本没有惩罚。
No, I know. I mean, clearly--
不，我知道。我的意思是，很显然——
He loved that kind of stuff. Like I said, he was wild. He used to--
他喜欢那种事情。就像我说的，他很野。他过去常——
I love the sort of strange nostalgic excitement you have for this borderline child abuse.
我喜欢你对这种近乎虐待儿童的行为所表现出的那种奇怪的怀旧兴奋感。
Molly Shannon talking to Marc Maron on the WTF podcast, which I recommend and which you can find on iTunes or through an internet search. We spoke with the other girl in that story who has not talked with Molly Shannon in a while-- didn't know that she was telling that story publicly-- who confirmed all the crazy details in the story. She says they held hands and prayed while the plane took off.
莫莉·香农在WTF播客上与马克·马伦交谈，我推荐这个播客，你可以在iTunes上或通过互联网搜索找到它。我们采访了那个故事里的另一个女孩，她已经很久没有和莫莉·香农说过话了——不知道她在公开讲述那个故事——她证实了故事中所有疯狂的细节。她说她们在飞机起飞时手牵着手祈祷。
[MUSIC - NIRVANA, "ON A PLAIN"]
[音乐 - 涅槃乐队，“On A Plain”]
Act Four, Pre K-O. To understand this next story, which is definitely a story about getting away with it in a big, big way, I first need to give you some background about preschool. In recent years, there've been more and more studies showing that preschool is one of the best investments a country can make in children's education.
第四幕，“学前班”。要理解接下来的这个故事，这绝对是一个关于如何大规模地侥幸成功的故事，我首先需要给你们一些关于学前班的背景。近年来，越来越多的研究表明，学前班是国家在儿童教育方面能做的最好的投资之一。
Probably the most famous piece of research on this is an old one called the Perry Preschool Project. This study began in the 1960s. They took a bunch of poor kids from Ypsilanti, Michigan, put half of them into a preschool program and then the other half just led their normal lives. And then after a year of that, both of those groups went back into the same public school system.
关于这个研究最著名的可能是一个叫“佩里学前教育项目”的旧研究。这项研究始于20世纪60年代。他们从密歇根州伊普西兰蒂找了一群贫困孩子，把其中一半送进学前教育项目，另一半则照常生活。一年之后，这两组孩子都回到了同一个公立学校系统。
And then every so often, researchers would follow up with these kids to see how they were doing from the two groups. They're following them still even now, and the results have been amazing. At age 27, the kids who got preschool were half as likely to have gotten arrested. They earned an average of 50% more per month. They were 50% more likely to have a savings account, 20% more likely to have a car. Preschool kids got sick less often, were unemployed less often, sentenced to incarceration less often.
之后每隔一段时间，研究人员就会追踪这些孩子，看看他们的情况如何。即使到现在，他们仍在追踪这些孩子，结果非常惊人。在27岁时，接受过学前教育的孩子被捕的可能性只有另一组的一半。他们平均每月收入高出50%。他们拥有储蓄账户的可能性高出50%，拥有汽车的可能性高出20%。学前班的孩子生病频率较低，失业频率较低，被判入狱的频率也较低。
Other studies show similar results, not just for poor kids, but for other kids, too. They do better if they have preschool.
其他研究也显示了类似的结果，不仅针对贫困儿童，也针对其他儿童。如果他们接受过学前教育，他们表现得更好。
And the very first state to choose to make free, high quality preschool available to almost every four-year-old in the state and then actually delivered on that promise turns out to be a surprising one. In fact, only a handful of states have joined it. Alex Blumberg reports that the story of how the state came to lead the nation in preschool access is all about getting away with it.
事实证明，第一个选择向州内几乎每个四岁儿童提供免费、高质量学前教育，并且真正兑现了这一承诺的州，是一个令人惊讶的州。事实上，只有少数几个州加入了。亚历克斯·布鲁姆伯格报道说，该州如何领导全国学前教育普及的故事完全是关于“侥幸成功”的。
Quick reminder before we start-- today's show is a rerun from a few years ago. Since we did this story, some details of Oklahoma's political landscape have changed. Here's Alex.
在开始之前快速提醒一下——今天的节目是几年前的重播。自从我们做了这个故事以来，俄克拉荷马州的政治格局发生了一些变化。这是亚历克斯的报道。
The state is Oklahoma. And to show you just how surprising that is, consider what happened to a guy named Ron Peters. Peters was a freshman legislator in the Oklahoma State House of Representatives, a Republican.
这个州是俄克拉荷马州。为了让你了解这有多令人惊讶，看看一个叫罗恩·彼得斯的人发生了什么。彼得斯是俄克拉荷马州众议院的一名共和党新任议员。
One of his party leaders, a veteran legislator, came up to him one day and said, the governor, also a Republican, appointed this task force to look into the issue of early childhood education. They came up with some recommendations. The recommendations were put into this bill. The governor wants us to pass it. Will you be in charge of making that happen?
他的一位政党领袖，一位资深议员，有一天走过来对他说，州长（也是共和党人）任命了一个特别工作组来研究幼儿教育问题。他们提出了一些建议。这些建议被写进了这个法案。州长想让我们通过它。你愿意负责让它实现吗？
I mean, it was a pretty mundane bill to start out with. It set up a public-private partnership, set up a private foundation--
我的意思是，起初这是一个相当平凡的法案。它建立了一个公共与私营部门的合作伙伴关系，建立了一个私人基金会——
Ron Peters said sure. The bill seemed easy to pass and pretty non-controversial. There were no state funds involved. It was all private money. The idea was simply to set up a nonprofit to publicize the value of early childhood education, so more parents would consider it. So he introduced the bill on the House floor.
罗恩·彼得斯答应了。该法案看起来很容易通过，而且相当没有争议。不涉及任何州资金。全是私人资金。这个想法仅仅是建立一个非营利组织来宣传幼儿教育的价值，以便更多的父母考虑它。所以他在众议院提出了该法案。
I didn't really think anybody would debate it. I mean, how do you debate-- just the private sector was going to raise money to fund the awareness program, so I mean, you couldn't argue about spending state money. But when they said will there be debate, about seven hands on my side of the aisle went up to debate against it.
我真的没认为有人会辩论它。我是说，你如何辩论——只是私营部门要筹集资金来资助意识项目，所以我的意思是，你不能争论花州政府的钱。但当他们说是否会有辩论时，我这边大约有七个人举手反对。
This is a nanny state bill. The government's going to come take our kids and raise them for us. We think kids should be raised by their mom and dad.
这是一个“保姆国家”法案。政府要来把我们的孩子带走，帮我们抚养他们。我们认为孩子应该由他们的爸爸妈妈抚养。
When I was elected, I thought I was Rush Limbaugh incarnate. And then I got to the legislature, it was like, who the heck are those people way over there? So--
当我当选时，我以为我就是拉什·林博的化身。然后我到了立法机构，就像是，哇，那边那些人到底是谁啊？所以——
You didn't think there was anybody right of you, huh?
你没认为有人比你更右了吗，嗯？
No. Oh, no. No, but there ended up the whole bunch of them.
不。哦，不。不，但最后确实有一大群人。
I got it passed. And it passed the House, passed the Senate. And then all the people started getting letters from the far-right wing, saying to the governor, this is a nanny state bill. Why don't we just take our kids from the hospital and take them to you to raise for us? And he got scared a little bit, I guess, and he ended up vetoeing his own task force bill.
我让它通过了。它在众议院通过，在参议院通过。然后所有人都开始收到来自极右翼的信件，告诉州长，这是一个“保姆国家”法案。为什么我们不干脆从医院把孩子带走，直接交给你们来帮我们抚养？我想他有点害怕了，最后否决了他自己的特别工作组法案。
Wait a minute.
等一下。
Oh, I was terribly upset.
哦，我非常难过。
Actually, the governor only threatened a veto, but it was enough to kill Peter's bill that time around. And that is how unlikely it is to pass universal public preschool in Oklahoma. A bill that simply suggests that the state might think it's a good idea for kids to go to preschool-- a bill, remember, that doesn't involve any state money and doesn't actually set up any new government programs-- that bill gets attacked as socialism and scuttled.
实际上，州长只威胁要否决，但这足以让彼得斯的法案在那次流产了。这就是在俄克拉荷马州通过全民公立学前班的可能性有多小。一个仅仅建议州政府认为让孩子上学前班是个好主意——记住，一个不涉及任何州资金、也没有真正建立任何新政府项目的法案——却被攻击为社会主义，并被取消了。
Oklahoma is arguably the most conservative state in the country. It's got a Republican House, a Republican Senate, a Republican governor. Four out of its five representatives to Congress are Republicans, as are both its senators. One of those senators, Tom Coburn, was named the most conservative senator in Congress by National Review magazine. And if you need more proof, consider this-- Oklahoma was the only state in the entire country in 2008 where not one single county voted for Barack Obama.
俄克拉荷马州可以说是全国最保守的州。它有共和党控制的众议院、参议院和州长。它的五名国会代表中有四名是共和党人，两名参议员也是。其中一名参议员汤姆·科伯恩被《国家评论》杂志评为国会中最保守的参议员。如果你需要更多证据，考虑一下——俄克拉荷马州是2008年全国唯一一个没有任何一个县投票支持巴拉克·奥巴马的州。
So how in the world did anyone get the conservative state of Oklahoma to agree to a dramatic expansion of the state's public education system in preschool, something that many conservatives would oppose? How did anyone get away with that? The answer-- universal public preschool came to Oklahoma not as part of a bold evidence based campaign, it was snuck in, in the dark.
那么，到底是怎么有人让保守的俄克拉荷马州同意大幅扩展该州的公立幼儿教育系统，也就是许多保守派会反对的事情？有人是怎么侥幸做到的？答案——全民公立学前班进入俄克拉荷马州并不是作为一个大胆的循证运动的一部分，而是被在暗地里偷偷引入的。
And to give you a sense of just how secretly it happened, consider this rather amazing fact. At the time Ron Peters was getting his little bill squashed by his own party in the legislature, universal preschool was already in place in Oklahoma. It had been voted into law three years earlier, voted into law by many of the same people who were accusing Ron Peters of socialism. And what's more, they had probably voted for that law without even realizing it, which is exactly the way that people who brought public preschool to Oklahoma wanted it.
为了让你了解它发生得有多隐秘，考虑这个相当惊人的事实。在罗恩·彼得斯在立法机构被他自己的政党否决他的小法案时，全民学前班已经在这个州实施了。它是在三年前投票通过成为法律的，投票赞成的很多人正是那些指责罗恩·彼得斯是社会主义者的人。而且更重要的是，他们可能在根本没意识到这一点的情况下就为该法案投了票，这正是把公立学前班带到俄克拉荷马州的人所想要的。
The story begins in the late 1990s, and it begins with a seemingly unrelated issue. School superintendents around Oklahoma had discovered a loophole in the state's school funding formula and were using that loophole to run a little scheme that involved kindergarten classes and huge amounts of money.
故事始于20世纪90年代末，始于一个看似无关的问题。俄克拉荷马州各地的学校主管们发现了一个州学校拨款公式中的漏洞，并利用这个漏洞运行了一个小计划，涉及幼儿园班级和巨额资金。
So the scheme was it was legal in Oklahoma for schools to have either a full day or a half-day kindergarten program. The loophole was that the schools got paid the same amount from the state either way. And so what school districts began doing was running two half-day programs and collecting twice as much money. And if they couldn't find enough five-year-olds to fill two kindergarten classes, they would pad their numbers with four-year-olds.
所以这个计划是，在俄克拉荷马州，学校拥有全日制或半日制幼儿园项目是合法的。漏洞是，无论哪种方式，学校从州政府获得的拨款都是一样的。所以学区开始做的是经营两个半日制项目，并获得两倍的钱。如果他们找不到足够的五岁孩子来填满两个幼儿园班级，他们就会用四岁的孩子来凑数。
We got right in the middle of that very, very early.
我们非常、非常早就处于这件事的中心。
Lloyd Snow was a school superintendent at this time who took advantage of this loophole-- ran two half-day kindergartens, enrolled a bunch of four-year-olds, and got paid double from the state.
劳埃德·斯诺是当时的一位学校主管，他利用了这个漏洞——经营了两个半日制幼儿园，招收了一群四岁的孩子，并从州政府那里获得了双倍的拨款。
It was like a no-brainer to not only be able to do this, put it in play, and then have money left over for other so desperately needed underfunded educational processes. I mean, it was a good thing, and we haven't had very many good things in public schools in my estimation. So I didn't blink twice.
这简直不需要动脑子，不仅能这样做，把它付诸实施，而且还有多余的钱用于其他急需的、资金不足的教育流程。我的意思是，这是一件好事，据我估计，公立学校里没发生过多少好事。所以我没眨眼就做了。
All around the state, the scheme spread. Four-year-olds were like gold, and the extra money they brought in went to everything from football programs to new school equipment, even new buildings. That's what happened in the district of Joe Eddins, a state legislator around this time.
在全州范围内，这个计划传播开了。四岁的孩子就像金子一样，他们带来的额外资金被用于一切事物，从足球项目到新学校设备，甚至新建筑。这就是乔·埃丁斯所在的学区发生的事情，他当时是一位州议员。
There was so much money came with these children, the school district bought what we call portable classrooms-- a big mobile home that you clunk it together and you've got a nice classroom prefab here. They bought the buildings, paid cash for them with the money the first year. Yeah, I mean, it's that much gravy, and then from then on, they got to use the buildings, in essence, free.
这些孩子带来了这么多钱，学区购买了我们所谓的便携式教室——一个巨大的移动房屋，你把它们拼在一起，就是一个不错的预制教室。他们买了这些建筑，第一年就用这笔钱付清了。是的，我的意思是，利润就是那么多，从那以后，他们就能使用这些建筑，本质上是免费的。
That might sound like Joe was happy about this, but he wasn't. This seemed like a loophole that people were abusing. And so for two years, he tried to close it, to keep four-year-olds out of kindergarten. But he got nowhere. And Joe Eddins, he becomes central to the story of universal preschool in Oklahoma. You'll hear a lot more from him later after he meets this next guy, another main character in the saga, a guy named Bob Harbison.
这听起来乔对此很高兴，但他并不高兴。这看起来像是一个人们在滥用的漏洞。所以两年来，他试图关闭它，把四岁的孩子挡在幼儿园门外。但他没成功。乔·埃丁斯，他成为了俄克拉荷马州全民学前班故事的核心。稍后你会在他遇到接下来这个人之后听到他更多的故事，这是故事中的另一个主要角色，一个叫鲍勃·哈比森的人。
Bob Harbison is a self-described corporate guy-- conservative suits, tortoiseshell glasses. He was for many years a senior manager at TWA, and after that, an executive in the oil and gas industry. He was also friends with people on the board of the Tulsa Chamber of Commerce. And one day--
鲍勃·哈比森是一个自称的“企业人”——保守的西装，玳瑁眼镜。他多年来一直是TWA航空公司的资深经理，此后是石油和天然气行业的高管。他也是塔尔萨商会董事会成员的朋友。有一天——
A banker friend of mine that was the incoming president of the Chamber brought me up. He said, I want to talk to you about a project we've been working on at the Chamber. And he said that it started in 1990. They had put together a little task force to evaluate workforce development issues because Tulsa was going through a pretty explosive growth period.
我的一位银行家朋友，即商会的候任主席，提到了我。他说，我想和你谈谈我们在商会一直致力于的一个项目。他说这始于1990年。他们成立了一个小特别工作组来评估劳动力发展问题，因为塔尔萨正经历一个相当爆炸性的增长期。
The banker friend explained that local businesses in Tulsa had a problem. They were finding it harder and harder to hire employees with enough skills and abilities to do the job. The Chamber had been looking into the reasons for this. Was it colleges and universities not training people properly? High schools?
银行家朋友解释说，塔尔萨当地的企业遇到了一个问题。他们越来越难雇用到具备足够技能和能力来完成工作的员工。商会一直在调查其中的原因。是大学没有好好培训人吗？高中呢？
They kept working back to this notion of increasing numbers of children not being ready for school.
他们一直追溯到这个概念，即越来越多的孩子没有为上学做好准备。
This banker friend handed Bob a cardboard box filled with research and reports on early childhood education and said, here, look this over and see what you think we should do.
这位银行家朋友递给鲍勃一个装满幼儿教育研究和报告的纸板箱，说，来，看看这个，看看你认为我们应该做什么。
Working through this cardboard box of materials in a cubicle at the Chamber, they and the staff had accumulated literature on this subject. And I became familiar with the Perry Preschool study.
在商会的一个隔间里翻阅这个装满材料的纸板箱，他们和工作人员积累了关于这个主题的文献。我熟悉了“佩里学前教育项目”的研究。
And do you remember reading those studies, like, was that sort of an aha moment where you're reading these long-term effects of preschool? Do you remember your mindset then as you were reading through?
你还记得读那些研究吗，那算是那种“顿悟时刻”，当你读到学前教育的长期影响时？你还记得读这些时你的心态吗？
Well, I tended to frame things in terms of my business experience. It was just sort of automatic.
嗯，我倾向于用我的商业经验来框架事物。这算是自动的。
Harbison said he thought back to his career in the airline industry, where one of the worst things you can do is fly a plane with an empty seat. But a kid who comes to kindergarten too far behind, statistically, that kid might never catch up. He's occupying that seat in first, second, third grade, in middle school and high school. But the seat might as well be empty for all the good it's doing the kid sitting in it.
哈比森说，他回想起了他在航空业的职业生涯，在那里你能做的最糟糕的事情之一就是开一架空座的飞机。但一个上幼儿园时远远落后的孩子，从统计学上讲，那个孩子可能永远追不上。他在小学、初中和高中的一、二、三年级占据着那个座位。但对于那个坐在上面、一点益处也没得到的孩子来说，那个座位简直就是空着的。
And also, he thought when you look at the statistics of what happens to a lot of at-risk kids when they get out of school, they end up costing the government a lot of money. They end up incarcerated or on public assistance-- bad outcomes for them and for society.
而且，他还认为，当你观察很多高风险孩子在离开学校后会发生什么统计数据时，他们最终会花费政府很多钱。他们最终会被监禁或依靠公共救济——对他们自己和社会来说都是坏的结果。
I always thought about if there was a business or a group of businesses and they had agreed to pay for all the outcomes, they would be spending money on prevention.
我总是想，如果有企业或企业集团，他们同意支付所有的后果，他们就会把钱花在预防上。
This cardboard box made a big impression on Bob Harbison, who, in his quiet way, became something of a crusader for early childhood education, making the case for it to anyone who would listen, including, sometime in the late 1990s, Joe Eddins.
这个纸板箱给鲍勃·哈比森留下了深刻印象，他以安静的方式，成为了幼儿教育的十字军，向任何愿意听的人推销这个案子，包括在20世纪90年代末的某个时候，对乔·埃丁斯。
Now, remember, Joe was this legislator. He had this bill trying to close that loophole and keep four-year-olds out of kindergarten. Bob Harbison started making the case that we don't want fewer four-year-olds in public school-- we want more of them. Here's Joe.
现在，记住，乔是这位议员。他有个法案试图关闭那个漏洞，把四岁的孩子挡在幼儿园门外。鲍勃·哈比森开始推销一个案例，说我们不是想要更少的四岁孩子上公立学校——我们想要更多。听听乔怎么说。
Bob Harbison is-- well, you know how smooth Bob Harbison is, isn't he? You know what I mean? I never knew I was being lobbied, if I was being lobbied. I just thought, well, this Bob Harbison's telling me the things I need to know, which, incidentally, Bob Harbison was telling the truth. But that was the key that Bob Harbison found me a willing pupil and taught me all I know about four-year-olds.
鲍勃·哈比森是——嗯，你知道鲍勃·哈比森有多圆滑，不是吗？你知道我的意思吗？我从来不知道我正在被游说，如果我确实被游说了的话。我只是想，嗯，这个鲍勃·哈比森在告诉我我需要知道的事情，顺便说一下，鲍勃·哈比森说的是真的。但这成了关键，鲍勃·哈比森发现我是一个愿意学习的学生，并教了我所有关于四岁孩子的事情。
Over the course of several meetings, Bob shared with Joe the contents of that cardboard box-- all those studies and research projects demonstrating the importance of early childhood education. And Joe gradually decided that he needed to change his law and make it much bigger.
在几次会议的过程中，鲍勃与乔分享了那个纸板箱的内容——所有那些证明幼儿教育重要性的研究和项目。乔逐渐决定他需要改变他的法律，把它做得更大。
He would still eliminate that four-year-olds in kindergarten for cash scheme, sure. No longer could schools pack their kindergartens with four-year-olds to get extra money from the state. But alongside that, he would provide for an actual program for four-year-olds-- an entirely new grade fully paid for by the state-- public preschool.
他当然还会消除那个四岁孩子在幼儿园换现金的计划。学校再也不能把四岁的孩子塞进幼儿园来从州政府获得额外资金。但与此同时，他将为一个四岁孩子的实际项目提供支持——一个完全由州政府全额支付的全新年级——公立学前班。
And it turned out Oklahoma had a very good pilot preschool program with guidelines for choosing the appropriate curriculum and hiring qualified teachers. But this program only existed in a few districts because, according to Eddins, the state didn't provide enough money to pay for it. Eddins estimates the state provided only a third of the money that was actually needed to run one of these programs. Joe Eddins' plan was to take that pilot program and fully fund it, so that any district that wanted it could actually get paid enough to put it in place.
事实证明，俄克拉荷马州有一个非常好的试验性学前班项目，有选择适当课程和聘请合格教师的指导方针。但根据埃丁斯的说法，这个项目只存在于少数几个学区，因为州政府没有提供足够的钱来支付它。埃丁斯估计，州政府提供的钱只有真正运行这些项目所需资金的三分之一。乔·埃丁斯的计划是完全资助那个试验项目，这样任何想要它的学区都能真正获得足够的拨款来实施它。
Now there was only one problem with this plan. There was probably no way it could pass-- no way the state legislature would ever agree to pay for a program like this. And so Joe Eddins essentially hid it. He simply offered his amendment again, the one closing the four-year-olds in kindergarten for cash loophole, only with some new language.
现在这个计划只有一个问题。可能没法通过——州立法机构绝对不会同意为这样一个项目支付费用。所以乔·埃丁斯本质上把它藏了起来。他只是再次提出了他的修正案，就是关闭那个四岁孩子在幼儿园换现金的漏洞，只是换了一些新的措辞。
A kind of PS in which he proposed a tweak to the state's school funding formula-- made it so that schools got the same amount of funding for preschool that they got for other grades. This was, in fact, a massive overhaul of Oklahoma's public school system, but the actual text of Eddins' amendment looked like nothing special.
一种“附言”，他在其中提议对州的学校拨款公式进行微调——使学校获得的学前班拨款与它们在其他年级获得的拨款相同。这实际上是对俄克拉荷马州公立学校系统的巨大改革，但埃丁斯修正案的实际文本看起来并没什么特别之处。
The way you amend a bill, the staff takes the sections of law that you're amending and then write your amendments in underlined and line out what you are deleting language. And I just had a few words here and a few words there.
你修改法案的方式，是工作人员拿出你正在修改的法律章节，然后用下划线写出你的修正案，并划掉你正在删除的语言。我就在这里改了几个词，在那里改了几个词。
Still, there were the traditional and powerful enemies to something like this-- budget hawks and limited government folks, which, as I said, Oklahoma might lead the nation in. Eddins' strategy here-- political sleight of hand. He drew their attention to the stuff in the bill he thought they would like and didn't mention the stuff they wouldn't.
尽管如此，还是有针对此类事情的传统且强大的敌人——预算鹰派和有限政府人士，正如我所说的，俄克拉荷马州可能在全国领先。埃丁斯的策略是——政治障眼法。他把他们的注意力引向法案中他认为他们会喜欢的条款，而没提他们不会喜欢的那些。
I probably sat down at their desk with each Republican and showed them two or three things in the bill that I thought they ought to know.
我可能和每个共和党人坐在桌边，向他们展示了法案中两三件我认为他们应该知道的事情。
And what were those things?
那些事情是什么？
Well, I showed them where we're keeping four-year-olds out of kindergarten, we're saving enormous amounts of money. You can contract with private providers, and they love that. That's all I said.
好吧，我展示了我们如何把四岁的孩子挡在幼儿园门外，我们节省了巨额资金。你可以与私人提供商签约，他们喜欢这个。我只说了这些。
Now everything he said was true. Eddins' bill did allow state money to go to private daycare centers to teach preschool. Also, his plan was voluntary. School districts didn't have to offer pre-K programs, and parents didn't have to send their kids to one. So it was entirely reasonable to expect that in the beginning, at least, not too many school districts would even take advantage of Eddins' tweak to the funding formula and offer a pre-K program.
他说的每件事都是真的。埃丁斯的法案确实允许州资金流向私人日托中心来教授学前教育。此外，他的计划是自愿的。学区不必提供学前班项目，家长也不必把孩子送到那儿。所以完全合理的是，至少在开始时，没有太多的学区会利用埃丁斯的拨款公式调整来提供学前班项目。
And one other thing Eddins had going for him, this four-year-olds in kindergarten for cash scheme, it was growing. And it was feared that the two biggest districts in the state-- Oklahoma City and Tulsa-- were about to get in on it. Eddins says that compared to the sure financial Armageddon that would be, his bill was the cheaper alternative.
埃丁斯还有一件有利的事，那个四岁孩子在幼儿园换现金的计划，它在增长。而且人们担心州里最大的两个学区——俄克拉荷马城和塔尔萨——即将参与其中。埃丁斯说，与那将导致的财务末日相比，他的法案是更便宜的替代方案。
Everybody could see that my bill was way cheaper than not my bill. If you voted no on my bill and killed it, you are going to have enormous enrollment of four-year-olds in kindergarten. And this was taking an immense amount of money. And all but one voted yes on the bill.
每个人都能看出我的法案比“不是我的法案”便宜得多。如果你对我的法案投反对票并否决它，你就会有大量四岁的孩子入学幼儿园。这需要巨大的资金。除了一个人之外，所有人都投了赞成票。
Probably because in almost all his discussions with lawmakers about his bill, Eddins left out the main part. You know, the part about how he'd put the state on the hook to pay for an entirely new grade level. He knew almost nobody in any legislature actually reads all the bills, and the number of people who actually understood Oklahoma's school funding formula you could probably count on one hand.
这可能是因为在几乎所有他与议员讨论法案的谈话中，埃丁斯都略过了主要部分。你知道，关于他如何让州政府为了一个全新的年级级别买单的那部分。他知道在任何立法机构里几乎没人真正阅读所有的法案，而真正理解俄克拉荷马州学校拨款公式的人你可能一只手就能数过来。
And his strategy worked. It was a huge and costly expansion of the government's role in public education in a state more opposed to costly expansions of government than perhaps any other in the country.
他的策略奏效了。这是一个巨大且昂贵的扩张，政府在公立教育中扮演的角色，在一个可能比国内任何其他州都更反对政府昂贵扩张的州里。
Steven Dow is the director of an anti-poverty agency and a longtime early childhood education advocate in Oklahoma. He worked very closely with Joe Eddins to get this law written and passed.
史蒂文·多是反贫困机构的主管，也是俄克拉荷马州长期的幼儿教育倡导者。他与乔·埃丁斯密切合作，撰写并推动了这项法律的通过。
I think it's fair to say that the number of people that understood what was going on in terms of the adjustment to the state aid formula, that most certainly you could count the number of people that were aware of that on one hand.
我认为公平地说，理解州援助公式调整情况的人数，毫无疑问，你能用一只手就数出那些了解这一点的人数。
Now if there had been-- if everybody in the state was aware of it, would it have passed?
现在如果存在——如果州里每个人都知道它，它会通过吗？
I don't know that I would say that I think it's likely that it would have passed.
我不知道我会说我认为它很可能会通过。
Basically, if you guys hadn't snuck this provision in--
基本上，如果你们没有把这个条款偷偷放进去——
Right, I would say had the enactment of universal pre-K not been done through this what I would call stealth campaign, I think it's fair to say that it would not have been embraced.
是的，我会说如果全民学前班的实施不是通过我所说的这种“隐身运动”完成的，我认为公平地说它不会被接受。
The irony is now that the law is in place in Oklahoma, it just adds evidence to the case for preschool. Researchers who studied Tulsa's preschool kids say they enter kindergarten an average of five months ahead in math, seven months ahead in writing, and nine months ahead in reading. And the gains are even more pronounced for at-risk kids who get preschool.
具有讽刺意味的是，现在法律在俄克拉荷马州已实施，它只是增加了学前班的证据。研究塔尔萨学前班儿童的研究人员表示，他们进入幼儿园时在数学方面平均领先5个月，写作方面领先7个月，阅读方面领先9个月。对于那些接受学前教育的高风险儿童来说，这种收获更为显著。
Lloyd Snow, the Oklahoma school superintendent, says he didn't need a study to show him that. He could see it the very next year, after his district started offering preschool.
俄克拉荷马州学校主管劳埃德·斯诺说，他不需要研究来证明这一点。他在他的学区开始提供学前班后的第二年就能看到。
I mean, one year after we started, I mean, we had to have department meetings and all kinds of stuff because our kids have better word recognition and letter recognition, better social skills, better hand-eye coordination skills, better-- just almost better everything, as it relates to readiness for school.
我的意思是，我们开始一年后，我的意思是，我们不得不召开部门会议和各种事情，因为我们的孩子有更好的词汇识别和字母识别能力，更好的社交技能，更好的手眼协调能力，更好的——几乎与学校准备状态相关的更好的一切。
So now, we've got all of our kids from whatever background, I mean, they're voracious learners now. Don't start me with that stuff. So--
所以现在，无论背景如何，我们的孩子都得到了，我的意思是，他们现在是如饥似渴的学习者。别跟我提那些。所以——
I know my ABCs. I know--
我知道我的ABC，我知道——
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So that was kind of a game changer for us, and I think most schools.
是的，是的，是的。所以这对我们来说是一个游戏规则的改变者，我想对大多数学校也是如此。
A game changer that, according to Joe Eddins, the legislator who arguably did more to change the game than anyone else, would not have been possible without the strange four-year-olds in kindergarten for cash scheme, the scheme that Eddins used as a smokescreen to sneak universal pre-K through a skeptical legislature.
一个游戏规则的改变者，根据乔·埃丁斯的说法，这位比任何人都更努力改变规则的立法者，如果没有那种奇怪的“四岁孩子在幼儿园换现金”的计划，这是不可能实现的，埃丁斯把这个计划当作烟幕弹，让全民学前班溜进了一个持怀疑态度的立法机构。
I don't see it ever being funded if you had it like other states do, if you had to say, here's a program that we want to implement. Here's how much money it'll take. Woo, where are you going to get the money? OK? If you would have to have a line item of appropriation, nobody would have supported it, except the young mothers. And they have no political clout.
如果你像其他州那样做，如果你必须说，这里有一个我们想要实施的项目。这是它需要多少钱。呜，你从哪儿弄钱？好吗？如果你必须有一个拨款细目，除了年轻的母亲之外，没人会支持它。而她们没有政治影响力。
What lessons could other states-- say, other states want to try to do something like this--
其他州可以学到什么教训——假设其他州想要尝试做这样的事情——
They don't have a prayer. They don't have a prayer. Because it's expensive, and state legislatures are run by people that don't want to-- they want to cut programs, not add programs.
他们没戏。他们没戏。因为这很贵，州立法机构由那些不想——他们想要削减项目，而不是增加项目的人管理。
Not everyone would agree with Eddins on this. In fact, if you talk to experts, the trend around the country is for more and more kids to be enrolled in state-funded preschool programs. States as diverse as Georgia, Iowa, Vermont, and West Virginia are all hard on the heels of Oklahoma, with preschool programs of their own.
并非每个人都会同意埃丁斯的观点。事实上，如果你与专家交谈，全国的趋势是越来越多的孩子被纳入州政府资助的学前班项目。像佐治亚州、爱荷华州、佛蒙特州和西弗吉尼亚州这样多元化的州，都在紧随俄克拉荷马州之后，拥有自己的学前班项目。
And as for Oklahoma, parents, says Lloyd Snow, the school superintendent, they love this program. And statistics across the state bear that out. Remember, parents don't have to send their kids to preschool. It's voluntary. But almost 75% of the state's four-year-olds are now enrolled in public preschool. However it arrived, it seems that universal pre-K is here to stay in Oklahoma.
至于俄克拉荷马州，学校主管劳埃德·斯诺说，家长们喜欢这个项目。全州的统计数据证实了这一点。记住，家长不必把孩子送到学前班。它是自愿的。但全州近75%的四岁儿童现在都已进入公立学前班。无论它是如何到来的，全民学前班似乎在俄克拉荷马州已扎根。
Alex Blumberg, he's the founder of Gimlet Media and the host of the podcast, Without Fail. We originally aired this story back when he was on our staff in 2012. Oklahoma's universal preschool program is still going strong.
亚历克斯·布鲁姆伯格，他是Gimlet Media的创始人，也是播客《Without Fail》的主持人。我们在2012年他还在我们员工时首次播出了这个故事。俄克拉荷马州的全民学前班项目仍在强劲发展。
[MUSIC - GENE CHANDLER, "I FOOLED YOU THIS TIME"]
[音乐 - 吉恩·钱德勒，“I Fooled You This Time”]
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and Robyn Semien with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reid, and Alissa Shipp. Senior producer for today's show is Julie Snyder. Additional production on the rerun of our show from Jessica Lussenhop, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, and Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Jim Nayder, Michelle Harris, Bianca Giaever, and Brendan McDonald.
我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克和罗宾·塞米恩制作，亚历克斯·布鲁姆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德和阿丽莎·希普参与。今天节目的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。我们节目的重播还有来自杰西卡·卢森霍普、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、斯托·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼的额外制作。今天特别感谢吉姆·奈德、米歇尔·哈里斯、比安卡·吉弗和布伦丹·麦克唐纳。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who lists his personal vices this way-- he has five vices. Five-- exactly five.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交流电台PRX提供给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他这样列出他的个人恶习——他有五个恶习。五个——正好五个。
Drugs, fruit, people, reptiles, and parrots.
毒品、水果、人、爬行动物和鹦鹉。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周再见，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - GENE CHANDLER, "I FOOLED YOU THIS TIME"]
[音乐 - 吉恩·钱德勒，“I Fooled You This Time”]